[Musik]
hallo meine Lieben heute gibt es ein
wunschrezept von Hamsa bzw er hat mich
gefragt kannst du die almondi
Mandeltorte selber machen natürlich muss
ich sie mir dann einmal kaufen aber ich
habe mich richtig erschrocken wie flach
die ist und ich denke es ist überhaupt
kein Problem die selber herzustellen das
ist eine mandelt Torte also mandelböden
mit einer weißen Creme und Mandeln oben
drauf und die ganze Torte ist glutenfrei
also werde ich sie natürlich auch
glutenfrei machen und ich würde mal
sagen wir starten jetzt direkt mit den
mandelböden und ich schreibe euch die
ganz genauen Mengenangaben wie immer
hier unten in die Infobox so ich benutze
heute meine Küchenmaschine weil ich
brauche richtig fluffig aufgeschlagene
Eier ihr könnt natürlich auch euer
handröhgerät verwenden dann braucht ihr
einfach nur so ein paar Minuten länger
und ich schlage jetzt hier die Eier
zusammen mit dem braunen Zucker auf da
könntet ihr jetzt auch weißen Zucker
nehmen wenn ihr den braunen nicht da hab
aber der braune gibt einfach noch mal so
ein karamelligen Beigeschmack und da
kommt dann auch Vanilleextrakt dazu und
dann das ganze so drei bis 4 Minuten
lang richtig schön hellcremig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
rühren so die Schüssel solltet jetzt
nicht mit in den Teig geben habe gerade
erstmal den Schock meines Lebens gehabt
wa geht erstmal weiter also ich habe
jetzt die gemahlenen Mandeln mit dazu
gegeben ganz kurz nur unterrühen
wirklich nur so dre vi Sekunden jetzt
kommen auch schon die nächsten trockenen
Zutaten mit hinein die Siebe ich aber
weil bei der Speisestärke halt gerne mal
Klümpchen vorhanden sind gebe ich einmal
durch das Sieb Backpulver auch direkt
mit dazu einal schütteln und dann
verrührt sich das vorab miteinander so
und auch das wird nur ganz kurz so kurz
wie notwendig untergerührt damit wir
eben dieses Volumen nicht wegbekommen
dass es schön vorhanden bleibt und
zuletzt kommt dann nur noch ein bisschen
neutrales Öl hinein und dann ist der
Teig
[Musik]
fertig so ich habe jetzt meine 20 cm
Springform vorbereitet indem ich
Backpapier auf den Boden gelegt habe und
jetzt wird der Teig eingefüllt nicht
wundern der ist ein bisschen flüssig und
daher auch am besten die Springform
verwenden dann habt ihr nämlich
Auslaufsicherheit bzw selbst wenn 1 ml
ausläuft dann haben wir immer noch die
auffangrille und jetzt wird bei 180°
Ober und Unterhitze im vorgeheizten
Backofen gebacken und anschließend
vollständig auskühlen
lassen so 25 Minuten später der
mandelboden ist perfekt durchgebacken
den gebe ich jetzt wie gesagt kurz an
die Seite damit der auskühlen kann wir
nutzen jetzt aber die Zwischenzeit und
machen die leckere Creme und zwar ist
das eine Creme mit Butter Kondensmilch
und weißer Schokolade und ich gebe auch
noch Vanillegeschmack mit dazu und ich
weiß dass viele mal abgeschreckt sind
bei Buttercreme aber wenn ihr das lang
genug mixt dann braucht ihr euch
überhaupt keine Sorgen machen denn dann
wird es richtig schön fluffig richtig
cremig und es wird nicht so ein
unangenehmes Mundgefühl geben also es
ist einfach richtig lecker hauptsache
die Butter ist zimmerwarm und wird
richtig Schlange Schlange richtig lange
hellcremig gemixt und das mache ich
[Musik]
jetzt nach 5 Minuten in meiner heiß
geliebten Küchenmaschine ist die Butter
schön ja wie sage ich die ist so richtig
hellcremig es kann sein dass ihr je
nachdem welche Maschine ihr verwendet
vielleicht müsst ihr auch 10 Minuten
schlagen beobachtet das einfach und
schaut dass sie wirklich aussieht wie
Frischkäse oder wie so Philadelphia
Frischkäse der der so richtig cremig
gerührt wurde und jetzt kommt noch
gezuckerte Kondensmilch dazu und dann
das ganze gerne noch mal zi D weitere
Minuten schlagen so Vanille gibt halt
einfach noch mal so den Geschmack
schmeckt einfach richtig lecker und
nicht so langweilig und und dann ganz
zum Schluss geschmolzene weiße
kuouvertüre mit reingeben am besten über
einem Wasserbad schmelzen lassen mit
einem Schmelztopf denn weiße Schokolade
oder Kouvertüre ist halt sehr anfällig
dass es dann auch schnell anbrennt und
so habt ihr einfach perfekte weiße
geschmolzene kuouvertüre aber ihr könnt
wie gesagt auch Schokolade nehmen
einfach das was ihr da
[Musik]
habt so die Creme ist fertig so sieht
sie aus ich finde sie sieht schon
farblich so aus wie beim Original okay
bei mir sind noch vanillepünktchen drin
aber darauf konnte ich jetzt nicht
verzichten so und jetzt nehme ich mir
den abgekühlten Boden da habe ich noch
ein Tipp für euch wenn ihr nicht möchtet
dass der Boden austrocknet oben einfach
Küchenpapier nass machen auswringen und
oben drüber legen das kann ich jetzt
einmal runternehmen und dann mit der
standardwinkelpalette einmal am Rand
entlang fahren damit ihr euch auch die
Seiten nicht
wegreißt dann einfach den spring vom
Rand entfernen bzw den Kuchenboden
komplett lösen und dann teilen wir ihn
mit der tortensäge einmal mittig durch
und da empfehle ich euch meine
tortensäge die hat hier nämlich so ein
Wellenschliff und der Boden ist super
zart das heißt ihr braucht einfach eine
gute Säge damit ihr euch da irgendwie
nichts kaputt sägt und dann mache ich so
dass ich jetzt hier einfach die Höhe
abmesse und dann stelle ich die Säge so
ein dass sie komplett mittig einmal
[Musik]
durchteilt
den Boden jetzt auf eine Tortenplatte
legen und auch gerne eine drehbare
Tortenplatte drunter stellen dann das
ganze mit der Creme füllen den zweiten
Boden oben drüber legen und rundherum
mit der Creme bestreichen die gehobelten
Mandeln werden dann noch in der Pfanne
fettfrei angeröstet dass sie schön
goldbraun sind und dann einmal rundhum
mit den abgekühlten Mandelblättchen
garnieren trommelwirbel
ich find sie richtig schön und ich finde
sie sieht aus wie auf der Packung das
entspricht der Wahrheit sieht aus wie
auf der Packung ne und ich finde die ist
mir wirklich gut gelungen da bin ich
richtig stolz drauf so ich würde sagen
wir müssen zum Test jetzt auf jeden Fall
den hamser Rufen also sehen wir uns
gleich zum tastest
[Musik]
wieder passiert hier ich hab gebacken
für
dich ach so
[Musik]
da ich sag ja das ist bisschen alles
geschrumpft worden wäre nein weil ich
kenne das ja von Ikea also kann ich das
jetzt nicht er sagt aber wenn ich
vergleiche mit IKEA oder w ich Vergleich
mit dem Bild sind mir ein bisschen zu
viele Mandel drin aber ist egal ich mag
Mandeln ja ich habe ich hau die Mandeln
einfach drauf da sind noch Lücken drin
das stimmt ja oder die war einfach nur
gierig weißt du nicht
nee mal gear hat beim tortenbacken
nichts zu suchen ah man hört richtig wie
saftig der Boden ist W gerade sagen hast
auch gehört und ich finde das Creme
bodenverhältnis perfekt lecker aber ich
finde es h doch bisschen bisschen länger
Kühlschrank sein können die war 10
Minuten im Kühlschrank zu wenig aber wir
müssen hier noch endzehen machen mit
ganz viel warm Licht warm ja und
deswegen also ich würde euch auch raten
kühlt die auf jeden Fall ich finde die
auch voll lecker ich finde die so auch
voll lecker und man gleitet da so so
richtig easy peasy durch mit der Gabel
und der woden so aromatisch aber man
merkt auch die grö Arom von von der
Mandel schmeck richtig lecker lecker
heute nachmachen hast toll gemacht danke
schön was mit dem Original willst du das
auch noch probieren muss Backen das
sieht so aus als müsste es noch einmal
in den Backofen ne kann man nicht essen
jetzt so doch das kann man essen das
aufg ach so ich das dann du musst nicht
probieren alles gut ja vielleicht Andes
mal nächste Mal gönnt euch diese Torte
die war auch wirklich super schnell
nachzumachen fris ist immer leckerer ist
immer so jetzt ich würde ein E das
Zerreißen zerfetzen weil frisch schmeckt
immer bessert immer das stimmt vor allem
wirklich schnell und einfach gemacht
also fast so schnell wie als würdet ihr
dahinfahren euch das Kaufen und auftauen
lassen also ich ge auch nicht ich ge ung
auch zu bcker kaufen Kuchen da also die
sind jetzt frisch gebacken da bin ich
auch lieber Team lieber ja kriegt der
hab auch mehr als genug Torte ne das
wiss zu viel B verwöhnt hier von deren
hier also ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel Spaß beim Nachbacken und schreibt
mir noch gerne rein was ich als nächstes
machen soll habt ihr irgendein du
meintest mal koppenrad und Wiese ne die
koppenrad und Wiese te haben s gerade in
so einer Welt also schreibt gerne die
vorsch machen ja das passt jetzt auch
gerade zur Winterzeit ja ma ich gerne
also meine Geburtstagstorte früher jedes
Jahr stimmt ich ma die dir haben s
versprochen also bis zum nächsten Mal
ihr Lieben tschüss
[Musik]
C